uh let me ask you this because
when nipsey died it hit the city like a
tidal wave i had never seen bro
bigger than even when kobe died rest in
peace to kobe yeah but you being in jail
and experiencing that
you know whether or not you had a
relationship with him just being from la
what was that like ex
like like going through a loss like that
for la like while you're locked up like
what was the temperament inside
i mean it was crazy because i ain't that
was the only person that i could just
like
be like all right that's cool he still
come to the hood and stuff like that
so after that i was like yeah i ain't
coming back like
i'm not gonna be driving the hood doing
the same stuff like
i'm like yeah that could happen to
anybody that was the only person i could
say that
was doing that so i'm like nah honestly
she kind of had me like nah
i gotta stay away when i get up yeah
it's almost like it
shows you like even like you know with
all the positivity he was bringing to
his
neighborhood like it didn't matter yeah
basically like people don't care
they just haters like is that something
because you know
i think that a lot of people they they
they'll go to jail to come out
and you know they don't necessarily
change their um
their habits yeah their circle yeah
is that something like when you're when
you're in there thinking about like [ __ ]
when i get out i got to reevaluate this
this this
oh yeah for sure for sure it's a lot of
people i'm dealing with that right now
i'm sure yeah i got it yeah that's all i
was thinking about
who to keep around who not to keep
around how was it gonna be
i just didn't know it was gonna be like
this when i got out like people was
telling me in jail like you don't know
like
it'll be people that just came to jail
like you don't know bro like
you know you think you know like but you
don't know how it's gonna be when you
get all like
you like it's a whole different like you
way bigger than what you think bro you
just been in jail for a long time
so you don't know then when i got i was
like wow it is different like